suppose you're around a field kitchen
when hot water spills over the cook and
burns him or suppose you're around when
a member of a while laying crew falls
from a tree and breaks his leg or
suppose you see an army truck smash up
and several men are severely injured you
don't have to be a doctor to help in
fact as a first aider you are not
expected to do a doctor's job or to use
complicated medical equipment what could
you do for a man with a broken back or a
severe burn or a broken leg would you
get panicky and run around in circles
because a doctor wasn't around you
wouldn't if you knew something about
first aid a first aider knows what
helped to give an injured person before
a doctor's treatment or equipment is
available he first determines what is
wrong with the injured person and then
acts quickly but gently and accidents
will happen
snake bites broken bones electric shock
burns such non-battle
injuries can cause loss of life or limb
if you don't know something about
first-aid sometimes accidents are just
around the corner
this truck coming down the road was six
miles from camp men were in the front
and in the rear the truck was about to
make a curve when a road hog forced the
truck to swerve Basava
a corporal at real injury and knew
enough about first-aid to take control
of the situation his first move was to
send for an ambulance then he started to
look after the injured the driver had
been thrown out of the cab and it looked
like curtains for him but the Corporal
started right in with first aid he first
examined the driver and figured he had a
broken back because when he tried to
move him even a little bit it hurt like
hell
the Corporal didn't pick up the driver
because he knew a fella with a broken
back should never be moved except by
steeled medical men he was smart enough
not to do too much he took a couple of
field jackets rolled them up and gently
placed them under the small of the back
by rolling the driver to one side while
the jackets were being placed this gave
support to the back so that the ax man
was more comfortable he reassured the
driver that medical help was on the way
and then went to check on the condition
of the others these men were pretty well
banged up this one had a bad flesh wound
on the thigh
the blood was oozing but not spreading
so the Corporal gave the soldier a clean
handkerchief and told him to hold it
tightly against the wound in order to
stop the bleeding
the arm of another soldier was broken
below the elbow that corporal sure came
through with flying colors first he sent
a man four sticks to be used as splints
then he gently removed the soldiers
fatigue jacket by tearing it down the
back
and slipping it off the arm
meanwhile the other soldier found
several boards and selected one which
was most suitable the Corporal tore the
victims jacket into strips and used the
larger pieces to pad the boards by
wrapping the pieces around them this
prevented injury to the skin and made
the splints more comfortable
the splints were then placed on the arm
and tied in place with more strips of
the jacket
the tires were tight enough to hold the
splint securely but not so tight they
cut off the circulation of blood they
were placed above and below the fracture
but not over it
a sling was made with a longer strip of
the torn jacket long enough to keep the
elbow at a right angle and that's what
is known as using your first aid head
this member of a Signal Corps wire
laying crew was up in a tree stringing a
wire across a road on the way down his
foot slipped and he fell to the ground
the sergeant in charge of the detail
examined his leg and found the left
thigh bone was broken so he prepared
padded splints from strips of shirt and
boards these splints had to be long
enough to reach from the foot to the
armpit on the outside and from the foot
to the crotch on the inside ties were
made above and below the fracture and
around the body
during the night a storm had swept over
the camp it had blown down trees
branches and the live wire Ryan had been
through storms before so he wasn't
concerned didn't even see the wire his
foot caught on it and the electricity
knocked him unconscious it was fortunate
that he was discovered right away by two
men who knew what to do first they had
to get Ryan off the wire and second as
he was not breathing they had to give
him artificial respiration immediately
in getting him off the wire however it
was important not to touch him they had
to use something that wouldn't conduct
electricity in Ryan's case one man went
to get a drive Pole
the other man took off his GI belt each
man stood on his drive field jacket to
insulate himself the belt strap was then
hooked under Ryan's feet
while the wire was removed with a
broomstick
as soon as he was moved a safe distance
from the wire he was given artificial
respiration speed was important
one of the soldiers made sure Ryan
didn't have anything loose in his mouth
such as gum or false teeth that might
catch in his throat and his tongue was
pulled forward so he wouldn't choke on
it
one arm was bent at the elbow so that
his head could rest on his hand the
other arm was put over his head
meanwhile the other soldier had knelt
across his legs placed his palms on the
small of Ryan's back so that the little
finger just touched his lowest rib then
with arms straight he swung forward
slowly so that he leaned gradually on
Ryan then he moved back quickly to
remove pressure suddenly and completely
but kept his hands in place he kept
doing this 12 to 15 times a minute to
the cadence of out goes the bad air in
comes the good air out goes the bad air
in comes the good air out goes the bad
air in comes the good air out goes the
bad air in comes the good air after a
while he got pretty tired so the other
soldier took over being sure to keep the
same cadence out goes the bad air in
comes the good air out goes the bad air
in comes the good air out goes the bad
air in comes the good air out goes the
bad air in comes the good air for over
an hour these men kept up artificial
respiration
one man massaging the arms to help keep
up the circulation Ryan finally started
to breathe by himself and regain
consciousness they watched him closely
to make sure he did not stop
after where they wrapped him up in
blankets to keep him warm and made him
like quiet hot tea or coffee was just
the thing for Ryan at that time and as
soon as they could they got an ambulance
and Ryan was taken to the hospital the
same artificial respiration given Ryan
would be given to a man rescued from
drowning only one thing extra must be
remembered the moment the victim is on
dry land he is laid face down and his
hips are raised about ten inches off the
ground to let the water drain out of his
lungs then he is placed facedown so that
his head and shoulders are lower than
the rest of his body if possible this
helps the water drain out while someone
is working on him
now let's see what happened to a cook in
a field kitchen it was noon and the men
were preparing the midday meal the cook
had had plenty of experience in a
kitchen but maybe it just wasn't cooks
day
suddenly the pot slipped and the hot
contents came pouring down over his legs
men were sent for medical help and first
aid equipment it must have hurt plenty
he was burned so badly they couldn't
pull his trousers off so they cut them
off laying aside the pieces carefully
they got some cooling burn ointment out
of the first-aid kit from the kitchen
truck
The Kooks skin was badly blistered and
the men knew enough not to break those
blisters if they had they might have
caused infection they gently spread the
ointment on with the wooden applicator
while the ointment was being applied
another man brought the cooks canteen
and first aid packet
you got off the wound tablets
and gave him all of them
he gave him plenty of water to wash them
down if there hadn't been plenty of
water for him to drink he wouldn't have
given him the tablets
since the burn was bad the men were
afraid the cook would go into shock so
they laid him on his back and raised his
hips and feet
so that his head was down
they arranged boxes and five-gallon cans
around him so that when a blanket was
spread over him to keep him warm it
would not touch the burn
they reassured the cook and told him
that medical help was on the way
minor dangers can all be treated by
first aid heat exhaustion
poison ivy bellyache foreign particles
in the eye ear and nose and splinters
whatever is used to remove the Splinter
a pin or needle or pocketknife it must
first be sterilized with a flame
a small splinter may cause a serious
infection if not removed promptly and
properly
now a dab of iodine from a first-aid kit
the glass container is crushed with the
fingers to release the iodine into the
swab in
then a bandage to keep it clean being
careful not to touch the inside of the
dressing
these men were on a long hike it was
summer and plenty hot
a private almost passed out from heat
exhaustion
he was taken to a cool shady place
clothes were loosened
and his field equipment removed
saltwater was prepared by dissolving two
salt tablets in a canteen of water
then they made the private drink plenty
of the cool saltwater saltwater is the
treatment for heat exhaustion and will
also prevent heat exhaustion if taken
before exposure to heat
wooded countries such as this is a good
breeding place for ticks this man's got
one on his leg this animated drawing
shows how the tick buried his head in
the soldiers skin and started to swell
don't try to pull it out these hooks
would hold the ticks head in the skin
and only the body would come off and
don't crush the tick in your fingers
ticks carry fever germs and you might
get infected but it's a cinch to remove
a tick properly hold a gasoline or
kerosene soaked rag against it for a
while or just hold a burning end of a
cigarette close to it
and the tick will back out by itself and
fall off
if there is a first-aid kit handy paint
the tick bite with iodine
poison ivy
this man's got it on his hands so he
gave himself immediate first aid by
scrubbing long and hard with GI soap to
get the poison ivy off if a rash appears
don't scratch it and don't scrub it let
it alone and report to sick call poison
oak and poison sumac get the same
treatment this could happen to you a
soldier got something in his eye here's
what to do close your eye and let some
tears gather if you're lucky the
particle will get washed out whatever
you do don't rub the eye rubbing only
makes it worse if the tears don't wash
it out it may be stuck on the lower lid
look up and get someone to pull the lid
down and brush the object out with the
corner of a clean handkerchief
to look at the upper lid roll it up over
a matchstick at the same time push the
lid down gently with the match
if you can't find the spec easily or if
you should get something sharp in your
eye like a piece of glass or metal do
one thing and one thing only see the
medical officer a bugging is here
but did he pick it out with something
sharp like a pin no sir that might have
broken his eardrum the soldier who was
with him dropped some water in the ear
and drowned that bug if the foreign body
is some object which may swell when wet
do not put water in the ear see a
medical officer
and by the way don't go digging in your
nose if you get something in it a gentle
blow into your handkerchief will get it
out
and if something gets stuck in your
throat try to hook it out with your
finger if you can't try coughing it out
a bellyache
this man hadn't felt the call of nature
for a couple of days so he figured he'd
take a laxative thinking it would
relieve his pain
but a friend of his stopped him he knew
a pain in the stomach could be
appendicitis and a laxative was the
worst thing to take in such a case his
friend told him to lie down while he
went for the Medical Officer his friend
was right that bellyache meant
appendicitis and called for hospital
care from where you're sitting this
snake is pretty harmless but it wasn't
so harmless to these soldiers who were
off on a reconnaissance patrol problems
sketching the terrain
the corporal was bitten on the hand and
he was badly frightened the soldiers
started giving first aid right away
first they made a tourniquet with a
handkerchief tying it around the upper
arm
and tightened it by twisting it with a
stick
this kept the poison from spreading to
the corporal's body they sterilized the
point of a knife by holding it in a
match flame then to cross cuts were made
over each Fang mark one quarter of an
inch long and deep enough to cause the
blood to flow freely
no one had a suction cup so a soldier
sucked out the poison with his mouth
something he could do safely as long as
his mouth was free from cuts or sores
the tourniquet had to be loosened for a
few seconds at the end of every 20
minutes so that some blood would
circulate to the corporal's arm and
prevent gangrene from developing
meanwhile the suction was continued
at the end of one hour the tourniquet
was removed
no small bandage was handy so the wound
was covered with a handkerchief a clean
handkerchief
[Music]
in this way practically all the poison
from the snakebite was removed and a
soldier's life was saved
[Music]
remember these first-aid principles you
have just seen they may help you prevent
serious permanent disability even save
lives don't get panicky don't try to do
too much no your first day and know it
well
you